2022 was supposed to be different after
a record-breaking year of home price
appreciation last year the housing
market was supposed to cool down
i even made a video about it
well it hasn't happened yet in fact home
prices this year are setting brand new
record highs i want to tell you why the
housing market has been so hot to start
this year defying real estate economist
predictions explain what we're seeing in
the market that suggests housing prices
really are starting to cool in detail
how home prices will affect inflation
and the economy moving forward
let's get into it
economists laid out some keys to a
cooler market in 2022 after 2021's
scalding hot year one of them was an
increase in the supply of available
housing and we've seen that
sort of the monthly supply of new homes
on the market in april was the highest
in 12 years
unfortunately new homes are a small part
of the overall housing market and at the
sales pace we saw in april there was
just a two month supply of houses
available for sale and even though
mortgage rates jumped from 3.8 at the
beginning of march to 5.3 percent in
mid-may there were still enough buyers
and not enough houses
so prices kept going up finally
inflation has remained elevated so far
this year with supply chain issues and
worker shortages continuing to drive up
prices
but things are starting to change and
we're seeing signs of a slowdown in the
housing market in may realtor.com noted
the first year-over-year increase in
overall housing supply since june 2019
the increase in housing supply has come
largely as a result of weakening sales
finally catching up to the market sales
of existing homes have been lower year
over year every month since august 2021
pending home sales have declined for six
consecutive months and are at the
slowest pace in nearly a decade higher
mortgage rates and average home prices
well above 350 000
have also taken millions of potential
buyers out of the market according to
the national association of realtors
more homes on the market plus less
eligible buyers
usually means prices go down and we're
starting to see that almost one in five
u.s home sellers lowered their asking
price in may the highest number since
october 2019. mark zandi chief economist
at moody's analytics tells me home
prices face a meaningful comeuppance
he's expecting them to go flat by the
end of this year or early next year with
price declines in a significant number
of markets
this slowdown is likely a good thing for
the economy because housing prices are a
major contributor to inflation with home
prices jumping at double-digit rates
economists predict rent inflation will
rise by almost twice the pre-pandemic
five-year average this year
and next year housing prices also make
up a major part of the core inflation
readings that the federal reserve
watches to check the economy's
temperature a sustained slowdown in
housing prices could mean the fed
doesn't have to raise interest rates as
high or for as long which could help the
u.s avoid a recession and we've seen
over the past year that higher home
prices aren't having their typical
impact of boosting consumer sentiment as
home prices have spiked to record highs
consumer sentiment has declined falling
to decade lows in recent months
back in the day the great talib quali
told us what the good life could be he
said let's toast to paid mortgages
lasting marriages tina ferris is king to
paris
living long making my kids heirs and
heiresses
that's all for now see you next time
[Music]